welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man reporting live
from the Daily Bugle net and this
morning a big plot breakdown of
spider-man 3 made its way to the web
through sources that are apparently very
close to the scripting process of the
movie throughout this video I'm going to
be breaking down everything that you
need to know from the leaker post
including all of the plot details what
they could mean for the film and where
the movie could be going now there will
be potentially heavy spoilers here and
whilst all leaks like these should be
taken with a grain of salt we had
covered a lot of leaks in the past that
have turned out to be true such as Joker
Avengers endgame a game of Thrones
terminate a dark fate and so on so if
you don't want anything potentially
ruined it then I highly recommend that
you turn off now make sure you subscribe
to the channel to keep up to date with
all the leaks and spoilers on the
upcoming movie and without the way
thanks for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of the spider-man
3 pot leaks ok so these come from reddit
user no sale 7 on the Marvel studio
spoilers thread and this place is
normally 50/50 on plot leaks with some
being pretty much correct and others
being completely made up I'll let you
decide as we go through it but unlike a
lot of the ones that turn out to be lies
this is extremely detailed and it
flashes out the entire story picking up
right after the events of spider-man far
from home the user said that they have a
source that told them that these are key
plot points from a very early draft of
the movie and it picks up not long after
the ending of the aforementioned film
the user said that in the opening of the
movie
peter is raided and arrested at his home
by cops and SWAT team members are very
early on in the film Peter is tried in
court and sentenced to life with no
possibility of parole and a
maximum-security prison
much of the first act is court
proceedings and Peter adjusting to life
in prison before all of the convicts and
even gods start trying to kill him now
there is no mention of daredevil here
which was an aspect that was originally
rumored to be in the film with Peter
seeking legal counsel from Matt Murdock
this was apparently going to be the
point that the Netflix shows were
revived before going forward on Hulu as
their own entities but at
moment excluding that this does line up
with things that have been reported on
in the past Peter discovers there was a
huge contract put on him by someone on
the outside calling himself the
benefactor some of you may remember the
benefactor from ant-man in the wasp and
before the collapse of the Disney Sony
deal it was rumored that at the end of
far from home this would be revealed to
be Norman Osborn
however this leak changes that up which
I'll get into later there's a couple of
red herrings here and there but
eventually it does line up with what
other sources have said so far the bus
carrying him and other prisoners is
intercepted in the middle of the city by
Kraven the Bounty Hunter as they call
him in the film
Kraven coldly kills the prisoners and
dupes it out with Peter Peter manages to
escape Kraven badly beaten but he is
free now a fugitive from the law and
being chased by people who want him dead
Peter disconnects himself from everybody
he knows only ever reaching out to happy
by a payphone to ask him for help if
possible and to leave a message for his
friends and family he is otherwise
resourceless we find out the mysterious
benefactor is actually Quentin Beck who
is still alive and working behind the
scenes to get rid of spider-man before
returning as the renowned Mysterio this
lines up with the ending of far from
home with a lot of people believing that
Mysterio was the good guy
due to the footage reported on by Jay
jonah Jameson now disappointingly JJ
isn't mentioned at all in the plot leaks
which sucks as he's someone I think the
studio would be desperate to get back
especially with how hyped everyone was
from the post-credits scene afar from
home the awesome rumors that he will be
popping up at some point in the upcoming
Morbius movie but we will see when that
is released next year much of the second
act plays out similarly to No Country
for Old Men where it's a cat-and-mouse
game between Spidey and Kraven Peter
spends much of the film with no
web-shooters and a new but rough
handcrafted spider-man suit
this is Cravens first time being tasked
to kill a superhuman and is clearly
having fun with it almost taking it easy
Pierre is caught in a race between
trying to clear his name upon
discovering that Beck is alive and also
trying to avoid the law and Kraven along
with other small-time hitmen and
villains who pop up along the way
Beck becomes increasingly frustrated
with Cravens failure to kill spider-man
and we find out this is crave
last hunt as he has been diagnosed with
terminal cancer and he's savoring it he
honestly just doesn't want to kill a kid
though this kind of lines up with the
psychology of the character as well as
major parts of his rich history and
Craven has always been a kind of
antihero which this plot leaked manages
to capture beautifully Beck threatens to
kill Kraven if he doesn't get the job
done and afterwards we discover that
Quinn himself has a benefactor none
other than Norman Osborn who is running
for Senator Norman eventually exposes
Beck as a fraud and proves Peter Parker
is innocent which swings public opinion
in his way before the election Norman
gets the credit for reopening the
investigation and finding the truth
before he's elected the final battle
between Kraven and spider-man is brutal
they get sandwiched by police and ends
in Kraven nearly being killed by an
extremely anger Peter Parker Kraven
tells Peter where Beck is hiding and
Peter lets him live Peter goes to Beck's
hideout which turns into a big illusion
which Peter defeats Quentin is arrested
all his belongings and evidence are
seized and Peter is exonerated
Peter reunites with MJ Ned and May and
he visits dr. strange who offers to make
the world forget and Peter Ponder's the
question and the credits roll and that's
all of the leaks that we have honestly
if this is what we end up getting and
actually be pretty happy this really
feels like the perfect tying together
the spider-man MCU trilogy and it has a
lot of big reveals twists and also
amazing set for the future spider-man 3
has been said to be the characters
quote-unquote endgame by Marvel CEO
Kevin Feige and this is packing a lot of
elements to it that makes it seem like
it certainly will be that this was also
said to be spider-man's darkest chapter
and due to all of the things that are
going on in it it certainly comes across
like that
I like how Norman Osborn uses the
clearing of Peters name as a springboard
to get more power for himself and we all
do kind of know that spider-man won't be
thought of as guilty by the end of the
third movie so when they do clear his
name is a smart move for it to spiral
into more problems this aesthetic has
always been a big part of spider-man
stories and watching him go from one
problem to the next
is what keeps the characters so
relatable so I definitely think that
it's a really inspired choice I do like
that Mysterio returns as well as I
always had a lot of questions about its
death just something about it didn't
feel that satisfying and if he does
return alongside Kraven then yeah that's
gonna be an awesome addition both Tom
Holland and director John Watts have
said that the next character that they
want the webhead to tackle is Kraven so
if this is someone they bring in I won't
be mad at it Craven's last hunt is an
outstanding graphic novel and it would
be brilliant to see that play out on the
big screen as those who read it know
just how good it is I am kind of still
shaky if this is something that we will
definitely get as there are certain bits
here and there that I'm unsure of but as
far as pot leaks go this is way more
detail than the usual bunch that we get
which are normally just about 300 words
long unlike then this is expensive
heavily detailed and it seems like a
structured storyline with a three-act
narrative that touches upon past events
such as the benefactor well it's also
creating new elements this sounds a lot
like some of the things that we've heard
are going to be present in the MCU going
forward for phases 4 and 5 so yeah I am
more on this side that this could turn
out to be true if it doesn't no this was
still a great read and I am pretty
psyched for this and if you're a big
spider-man fan as well then I'm sure
that this definitely has you pumped to
there's nothing here that I really
dislike and often plot leaks have me
scratching my head but this one seems
pretty tight so yeah I am happy with it
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these leaks and if there's
something that you want to see do you
believe them or do you think that we'll
get something completely different
comment below and let me know and if you
love this video 3000 then please give it
a thumbs up and make sure you check out
our full breakdown of everything that we
know so far about Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness which would be
linked at the end we go over the plot
details tie-ins release dates and more
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to see why this could be
Marvel's best movie yet if you want to
come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey or head over to my
discord server which will be linked in
the description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else then that's the best
place to be it's free adjoin and we have
an awesome community so hopefully I see
you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 boxer on
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming Ragnarok and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning it's like the video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on
spider-man 3 in the comments section
below
the winners gonna be chosen today on the
15th of November and the cell be shipped
out from then to ever gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you